the opportunity that I see is uh first
of all with a game at it I when I first
got into nfts it was because I I
realized that this is going to change
the gaming industry and we're starting
to see that my prophecy and my course
prophecy was kind of correct so a lot of
the gaming world is moving towards uh
towards the nft space this gives power
over gaming items uh to pick to the
users it also opens up the opportunity
to use your different characters in your
different weapons or whatever it is
inside the game in different case
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today I'm with Ori Levy talking
about Bitcoin nft and everything in
between
bitcoiner and cryptocurrency enthusiasts
since 2012. he's a digital marketer with
over 15 years of experience in PR SEO
and content marketing designing and
building projects from ideation to
completion and he has been advising top
blockchain projects for the better half
of a decade meet only
[Music]
really excited
um to spend these 20 minutes with you
talking about your own Journey talking
about nfts and Bitcoin and this whole
decentralized world that we're in
um and and and we'll get started right
away Ori take me back to 2012. what what
happens in your life that you get into
this Arena that you get you know into
the space that gets you really excited
about it
so when I first heard about Bitcoin and
decentralized money I really found it
puzzling but I was really excited
because uh I thought this could be uh I
thought this is a really cool idea and
I'll obviously also saw the investment
opportunity uh uh all this took me some
time to to really fully get it uh so
I've been waited I've been following it
for a few months before I first put my
my few dollars that I had to spend on on
cryptocurrencies back then but it was
really about this decentralization kind
of the anarchist in me uh was what kind
of made me feel like whoa this could be
um a really good way to give the power
back to the people and the whole money
printing problem is not new and this
could be the solution uh for uh the
centralized government control over
other citizens so of course things have
matured a lot in the past few uh for a
few years and we all have a bit of a
different approach towards how we how we
see cryptocurrencies uh and so I don't
think everyone comes from these same
values but I think that in in our OG
crypto generation this was definitely
the main uh
um factor in the main motive for people
to to get into it
and so take me back you know perhaps to
when you were first putting down the
first dollars because that's always a
really interesting sort of decision that
it's one hand you're saying yeah it's a
really cool technology you get power to
the people new consumer Behavior awesome
but but now you're actually risking your
own Capital into an economy that is that
is not yet clear or stable so what what
what made that move possible for you
personally
so I guess that it's it's about two
things one was the fact that I really
dig uh having the Intuit before I
invested and kind of uh really uh liked
the technology behind it uh so I'm not a
developer but I do understand the
technology really well and then uh in
terms of the risk that I took wasn't so
big so that helped me with that decision
uh of course the deal was made in cash
in some alley in Jerusalem so it wasn't
as as safe as it is today in most places
but it was a cool experience definitely
interesting
all right tell me tell me a little bit
about sort of your strategic mindset
over nfts and and you know just to to
make sure that we're all on the same
page maybe give me you know a one two
minute overview of how you see nfts and
then specifically what what you decided
is the interesting opportunity in the
last two years in the nft space
cool so my perspective of nfds is that
it they're an awesome technology to
digitize any asset any real world asset
as well as digital assets and being able
to identify them on a specific location
on a specific owner and on a specific
um physical item so this is I always
like to want to explain entities I don't
know if that's it here but I'll just
give my one minute or less explanation
it's like a postal item a serial number
uh were you when you when your postal
code is moving when your postal is cool
is moving between the packages moving
between the different stations it's
being scanned and so it's that one
package that has these serial number so
this is what nfts are are they're
they're
well they are attached either to
physical item or digital item but they
have a representation that is unique to
them
and uh the opportunity that I see is uh
first of all with a game at it I when I
first got into nfts it was because I I
realized that this is going to change
the gaming industry and we're starting
to see that my prophecy and my course
prophecy was kind of correct so a lot of
the gaming world is moving towards uh
towards the nft space this gives power
over gaming items to add to the users it
also opens up the opportunity to use
your different characters and your
different weapons or whatever it is
inside the game in different case so
we're starting to see more
interferability between these uh these
items and more meta versus supports
different connections and this opens up
a really exciting world uh that we're
going to see in the next few years
and share with me a little bit about how
marketplaces for nfts work so later
we'll we'll dive deeper into nft trade
but how do marketplaces for nfts how are
they structured and and what are sort of
the different forces that are acting on
them
right so there are
primarily two
um types of nft marketplaces one would
be a primary sale marketplace where
artists or creators would upload or mint
their their their nfts and sell them
there for the first time and then there
are secondary sales marketplaces where
most of the uh creators already have
these nfts or if you bought an NSD on
some other website you'd go to one of
these uh secondary marketplaces to make
the sales so I would compare that
between uh Shopify and eBay
a Shopify store of course and and eBay
so
eBay is obviously for the secondary
trading where youth after you bought an
island you want to sell it you go to
that that secondary Marketplace and you
try to look for a buyer
Etc and now uh what we have came up with
uh at any trade which seemed pretty much
like obvious to me and did not exist at
the time uh what is the ability to allow
people to swap nfts and not just
um
buy and sell them so when I when we were
kids and we would collect these uh this
uh football cards
um with the trading them a lot more than
we'd be buying and selling them actually
so you'd buy a pack of cards and uh and
you get one that you already have and
you would trade it with someone and some
other cheats that had a different one
that you have so swapping for me as
seems like a very obvious use case which
I'm sure will be a lot more
um in in use in the next few years as
well
I mean unlike
unlike in the the football cards that I
remember very vividly also the trades
that were happening in The Recess
between classes you know they're here in
nfts there there is some
um stationary
um monetary value or at least there is
some monetary value that we could give
to any nft because of platforms I guess
like openc and such were where there is
some amount of money that I could get
from my NSD whereas in the football
cards there wasn't really I couldn't
resell the cards to the store and I
couldn't really sell it anywhere because
I could the only thing I could do was
trip so how do you how do you predict
trading will will live side by side with
the ability to cash out and then cap
because to trade you effectively need to
find another nft that is pursued
presumably equal value at the time of
trade right
that's that correct I guess that that
this is always a challenge when when
trading uh takes place however uh there
are also lots of uh of nft connections
that some wouldn't want to pay a penny
for however they would uh happily train
them for other kind of useless or or
worthless nfts other award-facilities
and that opens up more liquidity than
what we had I'll with buying and selling
a lot of uh nft projects uh it's it's
said to say but some of them won't even
trade for a cents now and I'm talking
about ones that used to be a really high
high valued so uh they're very trendy
and if these are very turning this as we
know the current use cases for them
specificity which is
um without real real world value and uh
and so yeah there is uh that the problem
of finding a an asset class that has
almost the same value but uh there is
also people that wouldn't trade
something for money but they would trade
them for a specific uh either for
example it my a uh looks the way it
looks and I really wanted to grenade but
I don't want to sell my my ape and try
to buy the other one I just want to
offer my for that other eight so that's
a very uh uh good use case for for
trading for example
so obviously like with any Marketplace
um you need Mass you need scale of
people to be a part of it in order for
this for it to succeed and for there to
be supply and demand how how do you
strategically run NF trade to to create
that sort of balanced marketplace where
people can actually trade with other
things they want to trade with yeah and
nf3 is not just trading uh items for
items they're also trading for uh
monetary value obviously most of our
sales are still uh not sure not swaps
but actual buying and selling of nfts
however we have the swapping option and
the way we bipol that and we'll get a
little
bit more technical it's not really
technical but we basically came up with
with uh some sort of the white label
solution so it's called Misty protocol
and we basically allow anyone any brand
any uh exchange that wants to get into
anastis to open their own nft
Marketplace using our infrastructure
that way we combine uh we will basically
open a network of marketplaces that
they're all interconnected so
um you get liquidity from multiple
sources that are all combined into one
article because as you mentioned
liquidity is the most vital part of
foreign entities because uh because
they're non-fungible right so you need
to have the sellers all the specific NSD
and not just any right so uh Bitcoin is
Bitcoin average change but if you don't
have have multiple people selling nfts
that are specifically from important or
or connections that are doing well
you're not going to have liquidity and
uh and that's bad
I think one of the most interesting
things at least for me that are
interesting here is understanding how
sort of the consumer psychology and the
cons how the consumer behavior is
Shifting
um you know throughout throughout the
years and what have you learned through
your work on NF trade what have you
learned about the ways in which people
interact with with nfts what they care
about what they perhaps don't care about
what's been interesting for you there so
it feels like uh we've seen the cycle uh
really explodes the bubble really burst
on the NSD Market searching for down at
90 down by volume I think people have
realized that uh their their the project
creators have realized that they have to
come up with more than some fancy
designs for uh uh a 10 000 collection of
whatever animal they found and uh yeah
and then uh the the consumers have
definitely shifted from either really
just going into every NFTA collection
that comes out in the hopes that it's
going to make money into actually
looking and and waiting for them to to
see how they do and then perhaps get in
we've seen so many people leave the
space because they got burnt so I think
that there's this as caused a little bit
of a downtrend and and lack of uh of uh
belief in this whole space and people
are already uh uh you know considering
their or claiming nfts are dead which is
obviously uh bullpret uh we all know
that this is uh it put technology if the
technology is good it's gonna it's gonna
uh definitely remain uh just for a quick
uh use case for nfcs for everyone here
so they're not you bought a ticket that
was fraudulent but with nfts you cannot
buy a ticket for a show for example that
is not spill there are easy ways to
check that you're buying the real ticket
for example and this is something that
you cannot do uh with anything else but
nfts so just a very simple use case that
we all go to shows and concerts and this
is done definitely going to be nfcs in
the next two years
so interesting
tell me you know from your own Journey
or you know what what is it about really
what you're doing here that that
fascinates you so much it sounds like
you have such a deep conviction about
sort of with the future of this and the
potential and the different use cases
that are going to come out where really
do you get sort of your own inspiration
and curiosity from working on on nfts in
the subject
so I guess what triggered but my my
interest is uh is it crypto and it's art
and that those are the things I love the
most crypto Community is is awesome it's
full of really smart people that have uh
really made me kind of feel belonged to
something to to a Drupal it's a very big
group now but a group of enthusiasts
that really have a very similar mindset
in terms of their monetary or financial
extents and uh combine that with artists
now which are even more fun than crypto
people because they are their creatives
and uh and art is fun and finally there
is a way to help artists
um uh especially digital artists that
are super talented uh talented are
finally able to able to to make some
some dollar so I think that's something
that and I'm really excited about that
that will change
the markets and allow people to invest
in people and there's so much so much
other stuff that I think is so
fascinating
is this so is there sort of like ongoing
work that you need to do to continue
tapping into the nft market and
understand consumer Behavior or is it
sort of through because you have to both
manage the day-to-day company as well as
un continuously monitor the consumer
Behavior how do you balance the two
yourself so I guess I guess I get the
idea of help from uh from the rest of
the team so I I balance by really risk
you know uh researching and and working
at the same time yeah as you mentioned
it's it's a
from from the the minute I wake up till
the minute I go to sleep uh it's crypto
Twitter and it's uh it's all day long of
finding it out what's going on and
there's so much right I guess when
you're when you're researching a
shifting consumer Behavior it's not just
you can read you know articles about
what's happening you have to literally
experience it yourself to come up with
your own thesis right of course of
course and uh and really just keep up
with with these Trends and uh really
understand where everything's going oh
what's the latest hyphen pause and
what's going to be hyped in three months
or six months you know and uh you know
finding out these days in advance is
what gives us an advantage of the
marketplace is slow
so a few years down the line if we're
looking at NF trade well what is your
vision long term for NF trade
I really want to make sure that everyone
is working together and this is why
Nifty protocol was created allowing uh
so if you open a marketplace with Nifty
protocol you get to keep the majority of
the fees that you generate so that
creates an economy that is not
centralized and allowing everyone to
earn while uh also allowing everyone to
have their own brand and their own
Identity or this is where nfts are going
so a few years down the road I wanna I
wanna have a
a standardized Marketplace solution
where everyone is is a part of both
consumers and uh and Traders and sellers
incredible Ori I really want to thank
you for the time and for the energy I
look forward to continuously
um follow end of trade and and try it
out myself I I like the distinction
between sort of trading and purchasing
and understanding you know the different
use cases of our war we're heading and
personally or your own conviction around
nfts and around what they represent in a
new economy and in a new consumer
Behavior so thank you very much for
spending this time with me thank you so
much foreign